- hello everybody and welcome to this
very special Halloween episode of h3
podcast it is I rabbi Klein to greet you
the world the red the temple's greatest
Couture the Cantor is the one that sings
during service
now as Trisha Paytas had noted I am a
Hasidic Jew so I thought that I might as
well look the part here today on
Halloween
my beautiful co-host isn't here ela
where is ela oh my goodness is that okay
Simpson she brought out a knife okay
thank you a banana is much more
comforting than a knife so you can just
leave it ajar and so Wow Oh Jay Simpson
you're not wearing your [ __ ] you forgot
to wear your glove you uh you want to
try that again you want to come in again
no but you should come in again because
the gloves are very funny there I mean
they are murder evidence so I mean the
gloves really make the part so let's do
that again no no it's good this is good
this is entertaining bad okay
and I said Oh where's my beautiful coves
oh it's okay Simpson he's got his gloves
on I hope he didn't know the knife comes
first I hope she didn't murder somebody
with wait you gave me the knife and kept
a banana okay Oh J just gave me a I
don't know how to feel about that and
he's wearing leather gloves do they fit
are they too small on you they're too
big they're too big I don't know what
that means well it was truly it's
clearly not mine well AJ is obviously an
alleged murderer he was acquitted in
court but he did lose in civil court so
I think we can all pretty much make a
informed decision that he is a murderer
so good for you you know now I want to
show off you want to you guys want to
come make an appearance too because you
guys is your outfits are beaut let's cut
the Zacks oh because he can't really
move
do you know who he is
did that looks so good oh my god he's
haloed by light he has a pendant show
your pendant the gaze he's really young
he's wearing a white blouse
this is move to the left or right a
little bit so we could see what's behind
you the gaze of miracles Brad Oh Zach
really pulls off the bras oh I put back
on Zach I am so anxious now they're you
now I feel calm
you're really good I'm not smiling so I
feel like the gaze of miracles I was gay
and then he gazed at me and I'm straight
now am I saying a little lip twitch you
want to read what's on the sign behind
you it's pretty funny mm-hmm
go ahead come on every time we turn it
off I get anxious I'm gonna read it for
Zach you shouldn't turn around you keep
gazing Center it says experience Brazos
loving gift this gentle man from Croatia
named Bronson has a remarkable gift that
has helped countless lives people come
seeking help from life's difficulties
health problems relationship issues and
more and how did you get it just by
looking like cures all that by doing
exactly what Zach's doing right now yeah
during during group gazing sessions with
Brazos visitors describe being touched
by an invisible and silent power which
opens them to new and positive
possibilities as they assimilate this
power ooh
results in a greater inner joy peace and
healings life transformations and even
miraculous experiences so many share
excitedly I feel there was a bit on
there that I thought was funny where it
says he he does like nine sessions
gazing sessions scheduled nine sessions
yo he he gazes nine sessions a day in
their 30 minutes of peace
that [ __ ] stands on stage for
like five hours everyday just gazing at
people man it's so
epic okay well good job Zack is looking
like a thousand percent damn what do we
got from you from me you said you got to
give the whole body experience what do
you do rabbit a spine is that raw is
that the Ross the Ross of the rock
are you kidding huh yeah a rabbit has
mine come on where's the ring clicking
on the glass oh yeah and then you have
to scream like a like you know a dying
animal yeah can I get the full body
because you do look really good
come here come here stand in the toilet
yes yeah cuz you look when I saw down I
look dude that's Brad bear he's got the
Banshee and he's got the crazy hair
the blouse really pulls it together man
nice what'd you talk about
all right thank you Dad
Ethan Bradberry and finally definitely
how do they say last but certainly not
least we have Ian the employee let's go
oh yeah baby this is me when I'm so Flo
you want to do the line his mics not on
I won't lie this is definitely me when
I'm on camera awkwardly can you know can
you do another one with this is
definitely me when I gotta pee I won't
this is don't sound bite me well I love
Enzo everybody is is is really keeping
it 1,000 over here you know I and by the
way the Hasidic Jew outfit is incredible
and I yeah give it up to Dan and Ian who
went on a mission of possibly
today this is all do-it-yourself um they
put this all together so I thought the
Hat was real like expensive yeah this
[ __ ] dude the Jews really they shell out
a lot of cash for these outfits that you
wouldn't expect anyone want to actually
want to wear but there you have it
afraid oh really wants my glove so I'm
giving it yeah you can yeah yeah exactly
oh my dog ate my murder uh my murder
evidence
so today the the big thing we've got
here is a Halloween candy taste test
tear list which I am so excited to bring
to you guys I haven't had a lot of these
can't here we go we've got all these
almost get into that later but before we
do I'm so excited you guys I wanted to
want to honor something that our outfits
who we are for example Ella's banana gag
is of course OJ Simpson's classic gag
worked when he was being accused of
murder some of the interview won't have
to talk about it anymore
just did you do it no I did after we did
you do it nope nip nip did you immerse
two people super violently no no ha ha
wasn't me he's like all jovial about it
he had a surprise for me and I genuinely
was surprised I think it was his idea of
a joke and this is it a Twitter world
would you like to die hey to the world
you know what I always think about OJ I
always think does he get girls cuz
imagine like like imagine being in a
relationship with OJ because he killed
his ex he killed the last person I think
not only does he get girls you know he
got out of jail because he has so many
fans people don't want to believe that's
not e gonna do
oh well Ruggeri I mean he didn't convict
him because they thought it was just a
conspiracy yeah by the police I think
you get a girl's base
you think that some girls are coming
into the little bit of like I mean it
hurtles man Singh yeah that's if you go
that's their friend though cuz he's like
not in denial but I wonder if it's a
little like exciting it's like oh [ __ ]
is he gonna cut my head off I don't know
maybe I'll lose my head tonight you know
girl there are some weird fantasies and
of course to honor Zach's excellent
outfit we must look at bra so whose gaze
is such a miracle that he actually you
can call in Skype and get a gazing
session via the internet because I mean
let's be honest a guy like this can't be
everywhere once and his power and
majesty is is just too great
he must be shared with the world and
therefore on skype you can call in for a
nominal fee of $20 or whatever it is and
watch him gays live from his Spa in
Croatia
it looks like a spa doesn't his gentle
eyes with that would you say see he is
such a gentle
he does have gentle eyes and so do you
that's why you're such a great broads
when I think this just just five minutes
straight of this Zach Zach sweet young
Zach we call him here
for green green and great he's got the
gays he's got the light he's a load I'd
pay ten bucks to watch the dead air
Montez zach is definitely gonna win are
you not impressed is like not even
smiling it's not zags job to talk how of
course she's gonna win dead air
well if we all did it but it's dead if
dead air goes on it's my ass are you
saying I can keep a straight face she's
saying you can you could get yours
talking about just a staredown yeah cuz
that's not dead air well that's what we
called it when we did it like you want
to do that weeks ago you wanna do a dead
air right now no but is dead air just
like try to make the other person laugh
you know what I mean that's not dead air
it's just a staring contest I guess dead
air is there's no it's live on the show
that's why it's dead air okay let's move
on this is turning into dead air with
words what soap for Antonio look we all
know who so flow is but there's one
there's his classic one is almost too
graphic to even watch what is he up to
today does anyone know yes he posts
regularly on Instagram here's a real one
and see what we got here
so Flo he's in later housing wine later
hosen Oktoberfest was a success
excellent and here he's got a mask on
looking like a little height beast and
that's four days ago yeah he's very
current
oh he's first class Wow no please don't
please please please please please don't
let him have a child so proud to be your
uncle think please it I couldn't handle
you having a baby did I can't believe
he's until rolling in it he's so neck
deep and all these weird Facebook scams
easy to get addicted to trouble when you
get free first-class flights travel
hacks [ __ ] what's he got here what
is in this bowl salmon gross I won't eat
on an airplane yeah but what's rolled up
here it looks like salmon cuz he was in
Asia that was a Kurt that ain't a carrot
who serves a carrot like that looks like
LOX
yeah Luke can you imagine eating raw
fish on the plane I don't care with his
first class or not you know he gets for
his class again I wonder if the lady
behind me was thinking the same thing is
there anything in the world more
rewarding than this what's rewarding
about what did you what do you mean did
you know the girls not thinking that
anyway I get down the flow hole and I
just escape and of course Ethan
Bradberry I think there was a famous
actress find him for real yeah I think
those Elle Fanning hold on let me open
this back up now yeah pull up pull up
hello piano as we do this that is really
I'm super proud of you for pulling that
one off
now why is he got this girl candidly in
the back of his photo anyway yeah zoom
in again I'm I'm pretty sure that's Elle
Fanning yeah what's her name L ll e
alright someone tagged her in here oh
yeah there you go
bro that's not cool so he knew it was
her he was just trying to flick flex
probably huh cuz why would he frame it
so that she's randomly there I've never
heard of this girl but yeah that's
definitely her who is she she were
related to Dakota Fanning yeah it's -
could've finished sister but she's been
in some pretty good movies
let's see she's been in this Maleficent
Maleficent that's yeah oh she's been in
L AM L fastens well the new one yeah
yeah okay there you go good job so far
he was in super 8 movie I'm sure she's
wondering is there anything in the world
more rewarding than travel she's
probably on the waited to work idiot
okay let's get him out of my life spent
too long talking about so Flo and of
course he's in Bradbury who we honor and
love I can't say single bad things about
Ethan Bradberry owe them that he was
race-baiting and for a good couple years
but other than that we concerned we can
certainly look past the race-baiting
when you consider this
I think a Bruno Dallas what we got yeah
baby
sorry what what race-baiting pranks Oh
forgot all about that stomping on black
people's Jordans in the hoods buddy
Eddie of mine that's what I think Dan
you can't wear an undershirt under that
I don't know it's a good point yeah you
got it Saul how about you've been
bradbury confidence it's about that's a
swagger
well Kai sure is that like who wears I
mean it's like a it's like Miami Cuban
or like an Armenian he broke it I love
that can you give us one of your come on
forget about it buddy Eddie of mine bra
yeah oh no thank you
what Dan oh I hurt my throat I'm gonna
do it like him all right Cheers
forget about it ah this is my favorite
in bradbury moment this will always be
my field where we got some new stuff no
Bradbury's yeah don't 101 yeah yeah we
got that my favorite they're praying I
was trying to say thanks for watching
again Ethan starts threatening and
[ __ ] crazy for the charity stream
Ethan ammo can we get a live regular
what if we have a regular ritual like
every 10,000 what should we do to salads
cuz they voted to have salads on they
did I think we should chemically
castrate him because castration
obviously is too violent so you can give
him some kind of drug that will make him
infertile for less no good I'll discuss
it with them but I like the idea of
having a regular ritual does it look
better like this Allah or like this well
you do need to be able to talk yeah we
do have more well you're right we do
have regular 101 you know Bradbury's
been keeping up the reglas he's been on
every day on twittered having a regular
ritual and that that crazy guy actually
kept it up he made it all the way to 100
I'm happy to say you got a lot of
support and love to 3,000 likes 400
retweets
energy levels are high how many coffee
machines does he go yeah he goes through
a lot okay I was like wow I was a great
one there's still 100 of the regular but
wait as episode 101 is even more epic so
he's pledged to continue on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
when you start to get excited about food
you started like breakdancing that's
cool that he's that fat about [ __ ] dude
he's kind of becoming like we're getting
a cult following I feel like before the
regular here I mean he's really look
this has a thought this has 12,000 likes
people are getting into the Ethan
Bradberry box
I think I said something I said just
nodded I'm not gonna play is probably as
music on it but what it's even he's
singing some song like I could if I
wanted to but I don't want to but yeah
you think Bradbury's coming uh you know
his own man I don't we need to get a
petition to get them out here for the
charity they've been good to the mutters
I made sure look at this right here a
regular well anyway let's get to the
I've got a lot of fun stuff to watch but
let's get to the Cala wean Andy tearless
oh not before the break we got to go to
break in five minutes
uh is there any in you Oh J to show oh
no it's all the same [ __ ] just
glitter would hate were the world so you
know this football team yeah I said this
about this and I'm out here golfing and
eating sushi and remember how I killed
two people back in the 2000s oh-ho-ho-ho
well that one's crazy was it was it
really that long ago yes world hate
Twitter world I killed two people back
in the 90s and I also stuck up a Las
Vegas pawn shop or some [ __ ] like that
at gunpoint I went to jail for that one
he made is Halloween one and he actually
has a lot of likes it's kind of like he
always did no here let me look him up Oh
Jay Simpson Twitter the real usually I
mean usually you can get about 3,000
44,000 yeah use you [ __ ] know
he Murray's a mark
let's see what the comments are oj
justice Patrick Holmes for Halloween
Patrick Holmes right now I don't know
any that stuff when he sees this I don't
understand all these these sports
references so I really don't know this
Twitter world it's me
Oh Jaime Holmes now I know a lot of you
fantasy guys out there wondering if I'm
gonna play this week well ot tells me I
shouldn't he said wait these 10 days get
that tender ankle in that tender knee I
don't know
martyred is people with 99.9% certainty
eight world it's just me chilling in my
yard well my ex-wife and her boyfriend
are in the ground dead all right take
care
well then well while we wait for the
break Dan the break God tells us when
women words break I've I just look I
don't I will
are we loving dr. Phil or because I
remembered not liking dr. Phil sorry you
I'm stepping on her JS under yeah
they're like okay Ethan wants to go off
on me but she's trying to hold her [ __ ]
together
what can I say is just not a big enough
table it's kind of me and my man is like
a dining thing you think I'm
manspreading yes so do you think
manspreading is real that's been
spreading maybe dr. Phil I always kind
of disliked him because his content is
just so trashy but all of a sudden I
think we do we like dr. Phil no because
watch this video
I've been seeing some birds in my
comments that I need to ask you all
about so like visco girl bro his head
has so much makeup on it like like his
bald ass dome has makeup on it it's epic
as [ __ ] I don't know that's vseo girl or
visco girl or by the way is that was
that was thus kiss kiss kiss from Jeff
Goldblum or is it predate him yes Jeff
Goldblum what he thought about the the
spider-man he's acting I think it's
pretty late so what the [ __ ] is it then
because I don't know what it is
I don't it's been around for a while and
it's like innkeeper culture do you have
an explanation I think it's like hahaha
type thing but when you're typing on a
phone S&K or like in that position left
and right so was people just mash it I
think it was Jeff Goldblum actually
referencing the sick sick sick no are
you sure because he goes and I'd never
heard anything you play it I think it's
completely unrelated well here let me
let me let me play you this clip which I
love by the way why do you think
spider-man is such an important part of
you become better sometimes happening
this guy's on drugs this is the first
I've heard of it you know I'm
crestfallen comedic shattering yeah wait
how is Jeff Goldblum not like micro
dosing acid right now that is like the
cool dad I kinda want a micro dose LSD
in like 30 years every day he does
doesn't he I think Elon does microdose
sure seems like it's sometimes when you
see him talking
watch how he's looking at her but he's
always been like this I don't know how
can he be that much of a character like
he doesn't even know what she's gonna
ask him look how he's staring at her so
intently you probably guessed all this
to co-produce spider-man so it's looking
like spider-man
I'm not a business person you're
speaking whatever you say is Greek to me
but to all these the mountains of brooch
or the mountains of British are they
yeah I thought he was making some actual
like reference to Greek mythology
learned something right I do think that
he is referencing something that's going
really slow right now yeah I noticed
that too
what's happening come on okay all of the
suggestions are things related to Geoff
Kolb micro does these the mountains of
work out I'm sure well to be fair I
think that is actually not high on
anything but you might be ela that guy's
[ __ ] up on some is gonna make fun of
whatever she's asked and I'm sure that I
mean that question that she posted
didn't really deserve a more dignified
response than that anything she may not
be the first you know so it's like oh
maybe he gets asked that like a trillion
times today
what Oh think he's heard of it like a
joint what anyway well how did we get
here anyway
and there's one that says and I did we
have that on the soundboard no I want
dr. Phil saying it
oh well no we don't but we can nobody
cares about that original you know what
I mean I need this should we show the
original for today and there's one that
says and I have a feeling that somehow
knows this is a way inappropriate so
you're probably getting a really big
food out of this I love and all the
answers are just total like meme trash
like I don't think he got any a genuine
answer and like the millions of comments
you wanna watch the original and I hope
and I hope we do have to go to break now
oh well now I'm so sorry to interrupt so
sorry it's 30 seconds long this is the
original and I hope for all of our
wonderful viewers at home carry to the
car that means my backseat I've got a
million times does anyone get [ __ ] up
and drive we know now I mean ours look
at the eyes they look like down the
makeup yeah that's that is about name
worthy moment all right let's take it to
a break when we come back we're gonna do
this most epic Halloween candy tearless
I'm so excited we're all going to
participate we're all gonna have
different answers it's gonna be the
thrill of a lifetime do not go away I
guarantee you we're going to have some
shabbat shalom and and some mitzvahs
some it's fuzz as well all right guys
we'll see you soon
ever buy something online and find out
you could have gotten it for less well
take it from me there's no worse feeling
than losing money and not saving the
maximum amount of money possible take
them from me
ethan klein not a seed you that would be
a anti-semetic trope but me as a person
that's what I think there's nothing
worse than loot then not saving every
money you can it's like when you wipe
and you get a little poop on your hand
when you wipe nothing worse than that
not to mention once it happens you feel
like you could be overpaying for
everything every time you buy something
online luckily I've got the free browser
extension that saves you time and money
when shopping on lime honey scans the
internet for coupon codes and other
discounts are them like magic it
automatically applies the one with the
biggest savings to your checkout I it
knows about every coupon code sale or
discount at over 20 thousand sites like
Amazon Macy's j.crew Domino's Sephora
Target and more just shop like none just
shop like normal and honey finds you
savings and believe me it feels amazing
like when you poop and you only need to
wipe once forget about it am i right
here for example my beautiful wife Ella
who's obsessed with buying baby clothes
for Theodore way more than he needs it's
just last night was doing some shopping
at Oshkosh B'gosh which makes the bomb
acid baby clothing and just Oh with the
magic of honey Oh automatically applied
at checkout after its scanned the
internet for the best codes available
oh and I hope saved 42 dollars a 33
cents and I hope yeah that mean now give
me a break all right honey has found
it's 10 million users over a billion
dollars in savings that's a billion
dollars jeez Louise
listen there's really no reason not to
use honey it's free to use and it stalls
on your computer in just two clicks you
get honey for free at joint honeycomb /
h3 that's joy
honey calm / age three
holidays are right around the corner
baby and you know what it's time to
already stop just start shopping for
gifts now when I suggest to you
underwear you're gonna look at me like
I'm a god damn fool but let me tell you
something me undies doesn't make just
normal underwear
they have spicy prints beautiful
stylistic prints but that's not even
what's really important what's important
is that this is made of micro modal this
beautiful rare material to a thousand
times rarer than AB vibranium
it's so rare and it's the writ and it's
just so soft and flexible and breathable
they're gonna see this underwear I'm
like you know what uncle Jeff I pegged
you all wrong this underwear changed my
life it's that good speaking of not
wanting to leave the house on me undies
makes perfect hibernation undies and
long wear whether you're looking to
match me on news with your boo this
cuffing season or just wanting to cuddle
up with your favorite furry friend in a
onesie me Andes has you covered
literally the fabric is three times did
I say three billion times softer than
cotton and offers in sizes extra small
to 4 XL well model fitting them big boys
in theory got softer than cotton is like
3x softer than those cute little
marshmallows at the top of your hawk
coke hot cocoa me Andes knows it's
freaking cool which is why they're
coming up with even more cuddly products
this holiday season cozy up with new
robes robes Oh treat your feet and
they're soft new slippers and of course
match the fan with their soft new baby
bodysuit with brand new holiday prints
and cozy new products me Andes has got
the gift for you my dudes
mandis has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchase so
you're gonna get 15% off and free
shipping that's a no-brainer especially
because you get a 100,000 percent
satisfaction guaranteed so to get 15%
off your first pair free shipping and a
one trillion percent satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com slash
h3 that's me undies comm slash age 3
we are back Beru hashem base rate Hashem
Hashem will HOD look ner shel hanukkah I
so would it be anti-semitic for a non
Jew to address as a Hassid not anti son
Halloween ya know I taste a medical it
maybe just a little a cultural
appropriation ro it's like how people
get mad about oh ok so no so so yeah
what do you think that it's a little
questionable I don't have a problem here
but yeah well what if we'll probably
would well because you know you do it on
Halloween like it but what if you get
drunk and then you start being making
being like because you know they would
be like oh oh let me break some change
for you oh did I give you the wrong
change being all like yeah did you yeah
did you hear about the new Jewish car it
turns on a dime and picks it up come on
oh yeah get in huh am i right do you
know why Jews have such big noses
no because air is free thank you thank
you thank you we love our to jokes I'm
kid I kid the Jews I kid the Jews this
curly is not long enough I want to make
sure my Curly's right how's it look
looks good do you know why look at those
for you you could be a rabbi yeah dude I
totally could rock this bro you know the
thing about Jew jokes is that they're
funny but once you start doing like
Holocaust and gas jokes those aren't
funny you don't snack so good point
let's start so we've got the candy
tearless okay let me introduce you
these are all the classics we could
possibly think of and I think we have
pretty much everything here candy corn
tootsie roll Snickers Milk Duds
Jolly Ranchers M&M skittles Butterfinger
starbursts wooperz whoppers Baby Ruth
Hershey's nerds KitKat Hot Tamale dots
crunch almond good again
you [ __ ] yes I love that [ __ ] Almond Joy
Twix Reese's peanut butter cups and of
course Junior Mints we have it all right
here
ela have you tried most of these or
you're in the dark on a lot of these so
that's got to be kind of exciting for
you and a lot of Molly I definitely and
a lot of these I haven't had in I mean
decades you know so we are all prepared
to rate these the guy so is this
specific to Halloween these are
Halloween candies yeah this is this is
what you would find in your halloween
back for the most part yeah so let's
start with the candy corn because this
is a very controversial unknown how
familiar are you with candy I've seen it
in stores yeah so people really trash on
candy corn there's a lot of love lost
for the candy corn and so well let's
just you know give it a shot I mean you
know it's kind of waxy but I don't like
no see I like the candy corn thank you
I actually do like mechanical um why
don't you buddy you want about it I
don't like the flavor I guess just
tastes like sugar you don't like sugar
you but you like corn I don't like it I
don't like how it looks I don't like the
texture hmm so how so let's well you
know what
which way is that are they gonna write
to I mean I'm with you yes okay and
accordance [ __ ] f tear like the most
classic Halloween candy no matter it's
trash you always say that the discount
section yep get rid of it I mean for me
it's like a see what well I have there's
candies that I hate way more than this
one to romance a knife these
chuckleheads back here both love it Oh
what do you guys items a canyon I'd give
it a c2
yeah I'd probably go beat here it's not
the and shut up cuz after like five
pieces like you're over it yeah it's not
become okay but we should give it a D I
guess we got our devoted no but the
consensus which it is a democracy okay
kind not really but I think candy corn
gets a deal
so candy corns aside now this one is
gonna be controversial because next
we're doing Jolly Ranchers now there's
nothing I hate more in my candy pouch
than a jolly rancher that's gonna take
forever to really well you can spit it
out okay I hate Jolly Ranchers
it's so boring it's so lame they get all
nasty too because the wrapper when you
throw it in like a pouch with all this
crap it collects all this dust and
schmutz and I love it I just never liked
Jolly Ranchers it's too sour that's too
hard
good I'm not into the Jolly Rancher oh I
love the flavor but I know people like
it well am I the only one I'm definitely
like Jolly Ranchers you know alright
well we are back you up on that one
either
yeah I'm sorry you like jelly ranch room
I think you're alone in this one I'm
surprised you don't like that go ahead I
like it I'd put it on a tear
yeah 18 Sunday there for me I can't do
that well you're the only one yeah but
I'm I'm the one with the mouse a tear
what was your ranking cuz you gotta go
up because of Jolly Rancher if it was up
to me I'd give it up I give it a I mean
seriously I just is it
I might even give it a tap I just hate
all right I give it a seat let's just
say see because Chloe tears so it's got
to be no I use like a tear as well wait
you guys all give it eight yeah I just
know so do you guys agree that be then
yeah I think that's fair that's our
first time okay and even convince me see
what okay we should go be we got to move
through this but I think that you guys
really are misjudging this yeah I don't
know that these tearless work on a
democratic although it makes people at
homeless pissed because if I put Jolly
Ranchers in F everybody would down so
maybe it's good taste the rainbow right
this is gonna be controversial I've had
I'm not a fan I love skittles
but I'll tell you the problem with
skittles at first great delicious
oh you're like mega smacking your lips
right now is rough thank you for a while
yeah but once you get to a bottom I
guess turns into like granulated sugar
no it's disgusting right now like I kind
of agree with you there's a there's an
arc to it can you
it starts as I guessed here and then
drop right I don't have it turns into
like chewing gum yeah you're right about
that
so I know it depends on the type of
skittle the yes it always looks like
Eminem and then I'm disappointed when it
goes in my mouth and
not M&M so I don't know skittles I feel
like I think my suit is a classic
I think skittles is a B I wouldn't give
it a higher than Jolly Rancher I'll tell
you that I'd give it a see tail yeah I
go eighty really yeah I think could
weigh up the atomic its class honestly
it's skittles bro you can't rate Jolly
Ranchers hiring the skills I won't allow
it I simply won't allow it
I can't I can't even see those candy
corns at D this is so controversial I
had a feeling that this it's so
interesting how we have the I first of
all the candy thing is like the ugliest
candy I really like it it's awesome it
looks like a that's the top so
depressing I do wonder if there's gonna
be one candy that we all agrees the [ __ ]
that's what I'm interested in with the
20 we have here yeah let's just I mean
for the for the sake of the classicness
of skittles I just I can't go lower than
a B okay let's keep it moving I love
dots
I loved the name already it [ __ ] your
mouth up it makes you baby I needed to
go to the dentist after chewing on it
I've never had dots go ahead when I had
a dump when I had dots in my bag my
trick-or-treating bag I went for the
dots first almost every time yeah
they're good but it's a very accessible
candy thoughts definitely [ __ ] your
motto yeah [ __ ] your mouth up and takes
like a week to get it dang that's a C so
we're you and I have very similar camp
about to say C its
dear for me anyone else I'd give it in
us at what place one of my favorite
candies out you just get you just busted
always glowing
every time the swish does act the music
and welcomes on it's awesome
Ian go ahead and speak up on what I
don't want have to ask your opinion for
after your easy I hate this candy what
do you hate about doc because I take a
bite and I won't get it out of my teeth
in December well then I think you got an
S on top you got an F on top I think we
got to go with the C then I think that's
only fair I'm happy do we agree
I think it's fair yeah I think it's
middle - yeah honestly I know people
have strong opinions about this next one
nerds nerds ela have you had nerds
before there's just these tiny little
kind of sour candy they come in this
little box
yeah box they're sour I mean hit that I
always look at the full package you know
I get sold if I like the package okay
and I do like the little me personally
nerds was always left at my bag at the
bottom of my bag cuz they're just whack
like these they're like chewing on
little stones is like if you picked up
gravel and put it in your mouth
I don't like them they're too sour just
not it just doesn't do it for me I feel
like it's not an it's not like a classic
like it's not on the level of some of
these classic for me it's more like fun
it's like a funny I mean here's the
Panda if you were wondering right here
oh no it's a classic you'll you'll end
up with like 20 of these a little box
though normally okay yeah that's like a
big box and you shake it yeah so go
ahead you guys I don't know
I like nerds I like sour candy I put it
at like an A or B personally they're up
there
I was gonna go in to see
for me they're dirty I know that's
controversial I'm going d2o
I'd give them an E and E yeah so the
consensus that nerd suck well not fast I
mean I think it's a D based on consensus
we're taking a couple I feel very
nostalgic eating it no no I I never had
it as a kid but I feel like it's the
colors they fool you with the colors
it's like nostalgic colors but Jesus
criminy I like the flavor same tears
candy yeah it's not no the corn has to
go down yeah the corn needs to go up I
agree with is the corn should be C rank
and the Nerds suck they should be deep
you guys can't rock the boat the Nerds
are D and that's fine that's insane okay
my mind fine D corn and nerds are of
annual kind it's not gonna be on there
man you guys are just wrong I feel like
okay so this next one has always and
forever been one of my favorites when I
go when I would go to a theater as a kid
I would get Junior Mints my one of my
favorite episodes of Seinfeld the junior
minute all right it's chocolatey it's
mint I love chocolate and mint combo the
center's a little coming so what I like
to do is you can fridge them or freeze
them and it becomes like it's not it
firms up but junior manager so for me
Junior Mints is like a great adult candy
mmm does that make sense
I like it nowadays okay I don't know if
it would have been my thing as a kid I
loved it as a kid
maybe I'm just mature for my age what do
you guys think a junior manager I'm not
a big fan of mint and chocolate but like
them but I but I recognize that that
yeah exactly that I'm not in the
majority there and it's a
well-put-together candy okay bad so I
won't really dock it too many points
it's not for me but
it's Lawson I put it at like B or C yeah
D or C you know BB or steer go ahead
dumb guys come on speak up um I'd give
it a I'd probably give it a C in yeah
I'm feeling C as well I want to go go B
I can't give it an 8 cause you guys are
pulling me down we're going you wanted a
I think but I think is what is what oh
I'm just I'm so curious what's gonna
make it to the top this is this is
exciting you guys I already have my eyes
on a couple I think I know yes the thing
is that the chocolates are always better
but do we have here everything
everything everything cuz it doesn't
look like it okay tamale you've never
had hot tamales yeah is one of my
all-time favorites all along side Junior
Mints I used to get him at the movie
theater you can eat him real fast and
they're hot or you can suck the heat off
and then your heart tastes with his left
with is really delicious guard it's not
right
I don't know when these in like 20 years
probably mmm it's cinnamon eNOS bite you
know you don't like it it's an
experience it's fun right it's really
good I want to say it's tasty what but I
would I don't think I'm my friend over
the flavor but I like the experience
interesting so what does that mean
probably a see backstage hate cinnamon
should DM be maybe guys Nina and Zach
help me I'd give it an A
oh me too it's like a burn so good like
I mean a lot of them I love hot tamales
now I'm going to e what Wow in [ __ ] it
up for us yeah say what why actually so
hold on why do you guys rate it so low I
don't like mission
yeah I don't like dying eula the
cinnamon flavor seven flavor gum big red
gum like any other sounds like a C then
yeah that's a big compromise but alright
a big compromise come on what do you
think it should be a D no no I want it
to be an A but yeah and I put it a - I
mean that's season if I was looking at
if I'm looking at our choices so far I
think this is like a very scientific you
know how they say there was this
experiment where you put a jar full of a
lot of stuff like you guys have all
probably seen this where you fill a jar
with jellybeans and everyone guesses how
many jellybeans there are and a lot are
super far off and some are really close
but when you take everybody's guess and
average it it's always almost exactly
right the group decides correctly and in
and in that spirit I think that the
group is deciding in a very just way
here
do you think I'm understand interesting
but because if each of us made it alone
it would be so different
exactly but this is a good universal
where we're at here again I mean guys
this tootsie roll I mean it's most
beloved it's a touchy rolls been around
for I mean a hundred years tootsie rolls
been around it's at the center of the
Tootsie Pop it's chocolatey its chewy
and now is this where we are like
complete opposite for me to cool it
probably and it's an A or Nash from me
it's probably or F Y same I don't like
anything about it this [ __ ] looks like
grandpa's best candy I don't like how it
looks it and then it's brown yellow
color and then they've how chew it is
yeah it's chocolate
low quality chocolate though like the
lowest of the low claws that's not at
guys are really taking me off anyone
else got my back he'll spit it out out
give it enough it's probably my favorite
that my boy
Ian I'm gonna go D justify guys expand
it is low quality chocolate it is it's
not trying to be chocolate caramel its
iconic about iconic men real what why
don't why do you hate it in the
presentation is terrible it's too gummy
it's just like it's not good everything
about it listen at the description does
he roll is a mildly chocolate flavored
taffy like candy hello I like it do you
like taffy to be you're right exactly
it's it's trying to have its footing too
many too many places explain how it's
been around a hundred years everybody's
favorite candy things out for a thousand
years
it breaks barriers yeah but my grandma's
been around that talk some things are
timeless unlike your grandma so it
sounds like a C then because it's like
it cuz in 2009 and became certified
Kosher by the Orthodox Union various
well there you go these guys are selling
international they got that kosher
market even well I guess you love it you
hate it it's right in the middle than a
sea that breaks my heart
okay guys again yeah I'm really putting
my heart out here because I'm bringing
again out one of my favorites that I
think you guys are gonna Travis let's
try Sunday okay
I so this is like my all-time favorite
during Halloween The Milk Duds was like
Mamma Mia daddy likey The Milk Duds
you got this tiny little pouch but
they're so fat they're so fat you can
only fit like 2 or 3 in it oh yeah milk
milk milk though
you know what I like Milk Duds too and
to round out the point about the tootsie
roll
look dudes are like tootsie rolls done
right because it's like yeah I'm thing
but much better
I like the necktie better than this
little absolutely whoa you're gonna do
it chewy chocolate it's the hormone
wrapped in chocolate and a little dud
bomb the chocolate pulls it all together
who makes this this is made by Hershey
Company anyone else goes up there for me
I'll give it like a B or na Wow I'd give
it I probably give it a see there's just
no consensus just don't like it's like
too chewy it is very very that's a
tootsie roll is worse for me no the milk
the milk dud is probably the worst chewy
ever like that [ __ ] does not for this
one beer to be to you for me okay so it
doesn't I'm going to be hmm
I think we might have to cuz it it
sounded like it's like an ass for you
Ethan
yeah I think it's a tear oh yeah I think
milk dud might actually be our first a
tear that's surprising I thought you
guys were gonna just like it well I love
love love it yes I said a or b so I'll
just say sure I mean everybody liked the
milk dud yeah let's go let's go with a
classic next Snickers this is timeless
classic candy beloved by all I mean
there's nothing more classic than a
Snickers bar there really is it so true
and I have to tell you I get it
I love this sink oh what a parent does
tofu is about the caramel it's got the
chocolate
it's all happening the flavors work yeah
you can't argue on this one let's see
it's so good to me Snickers is good but
they're they're better chocolate bars so
I mean I would give it give it like a C
or B I think I give Snickers an ass Wow
I give it an ass oh no it's not my
personal favorites as good as it gets
though yeah it's like they figured it
out mm-hmm we're gonna get to some
chocolate bars later that I think rate
above it Ian and Zach can you please not
make me ask for your opinion every time
I give it an a an a I'm doing a two so I
think I gets an A then yeah that's
that's fair I mean it has to be like
this one was highly rated overall than
the duds you think it had a higher
rating than the duds everyone I put it
at s and you did but I can't go s unless
we have like I gave it already though
yeah so that pulls down the average a
little bit I think is fair I think so
what do we got next here mmm mmm fun
side baby me too that's the [ __ ]
with these nerds mmm always happy to get
it crunchy chocolaty
I love the hardshell that's a no bomb
who agrees Oh to this day I love mmm I
love peanut okay you gotta get that
heals up and gonna kill our dogs
I'll give it a I'll give it an A I love
peanut butter mmm
I love all the new flavors are coming
out with a little too almond I'll give
it a day I give it an A - so then what
did you we go I gave you an S I give it
a s as well but ultimately what I do
rate mmm if I think it's go to add you
got three days and
asses anyone who changed about to ass
like an a to me a plus sometimes I like
the peanut M&Ms more so I didn't give it
an agree well we really like Eminem is
alone if an Eminem can't get a test and
I don't know what is going to but I
think it's an aid
I think it's an S it's an a maybe both
what Ian just said I'm including the
peanut butter and all of them no those
are different candies yeah we don't have
that what you wanna write like every
flavor yeah by the way you guys messed
up not getting those peanut butter ones
actually it came in a variety pack you
do mi name is anonym in my opinion all
flavors I rate them all the same I think
it's an A I'm sorry to say the S Class
needs to be so pure so in disputable at
the least it needs to be majority we
have to carry out of five dresses that's
yes okay but ela you generally don't
like the chewy snacks and Dan doesn't
like the chewy snacks bye-bye well chewy
wasn't the problem with the tootsie roll
it's the low quality just trash
ingredients okay
slow down okay starburst everybody throw
back is like SSS FF it depends on the
color for me oh come on we're not gonna
write the pink starburst alone puts it a
nest here for me as well pink starburst
starburst isn't hate for me it's not
asses guys I may have to go ass on the
surface I'd go as 200 I just I I it's
not an ass it's not per minute but
clearly they're individually wrapped
dude the starbursts people really
figured it out that that's by far a
highest rate of candy mm-hmm interesting
hmm
the best now let's go with the classic
Hershey chocolate because this one is
her she's so funny to me cuz it is here
it's like the classic chocolate but I
think it's an American thing and to me
it's not tasty at all yeah it this is a
high love chocolate so Hershey's is I
very contested oh I'm sorry I just ran
over our dog I'm sorry
we just ran over Alfredo's my wheels so
I hit on him why what does that mean
I've always liked Hershey's but when I
had German exchange students come they
told me that Hershey's they all said
Hershey's tastes like a vomit they say
it tastes like unnatural ungodly weird
yeah and when I first moved here you
were like I don't know you bought these
like this is a classic chocolate and I
was all hyped up and I might taste a
taste like [ __ ]
there's it there is a taste there but to
me is a very nostalgic taste that I like
but there's something kind of weird in
there so weird I don't got it what do
you rate that it's hard because I love
chocolate but I feel like this is like
the worst chocolate so I would put that
II I ready to see I like it though
actually yeah Dee it's not good like
especially there's so much better
chocolate bars like if you're gonna get
a chocolate bar dots yeah I'm doing Dee
give it a deep that's a D then you guys
outweighed my C was too generous here's
a wild card
Almond Joy
this isn't a candy adder not much about
in my life I don't think I've ever
tasted that but I can tell you when I
got this to my trick-or-treating bag I
was not excited about it but that's an
adult oh it's got like marzipan in it oh
it's like coconut it's chocolate
that's like the candy your dad would
want yeah I don't think any kid would
want this yeah it's a straight-up F what
K beware that D for me it's F come on
this is something we're deeming about it
I think it's AE them oh yeah sounds like
an e well there you go we're getting a
really good spread here I'm very happy
with how this is coming out yeah but
that makes sense to me almond joy really
isn't easy isn't it I love that
starburst isn't s that shock the hell
out of me I know people like star bottom
that's perfection
okay next up let's go whoppers that's a
little wild card I really actually I
don't know how people feel about
whoppers
I've always liked it look how it comes
there's three of them like a little tube
I've always enjoyed them I find them to
be refreshing break from the really
heavy chocolate the snacks that you you
get and I always like kicking these back
a little bread it's like a bratty
crunchy chocolaty joy but also weird
flavor in there yeah this expired no
that's how it tastes I don't know why
there's that weird flavor to be honest
with you that weird flavor really demo
ah down to uh to the expired section no
it's not a nice table ready whoppers
that flavor is problematic I have to
tell you in theory I like them but Jerry
I would love to
I get mostly I'm teetering between C and
D I'm going deep well again what was
your vote because I was like II
so it's a bit sad tea that makes sense
actually it belongs with nerds
no way now here's a while you love her
she's crunch it's different I'm telling
you the her she doesn't look like her I
love the crunch hit that first of all
rice it's dried rice and chocolate
brilliant
it's tasty its crunchy its Airy it's
light it's a dream no chocolate let me
evaluate there's something with American
chocolate is is not it's not it doesn't
deliver I know what you mean
a chocolate feels a little low quality
again I would like it but the flavor is
not it's ok was like the crunch with the
chocolate just it's not there for me
what would I rate it I think you know
it's somewhere between C and B from him
it's probably a D for me or D yeah the
first one I diverged from you on either
because I like Crunch Bars
I like it probably be give it a beat I
agree a b2 I think I think it belongs up
there uh how girls see I think I could
go see I think it's a C then cuz I was
kind of but you gave it a see yeah oh
then it's got to be a B cuz you guys
were kind of high on the Bordeaux put
the crunch bar okay oh wow oK we've got
some big boys on the board here we got
Butterfinger Baby Ruth KitKat I expect
big things from Kit Kat Reese's Peanut
Butter Cup also and Twix these are elect
with the big boys I mean these are the
big names in chocolate let's go
Butterfinger I feel like this is a
controversial one you know about
Butterfinger EULA I don't know if I had
it it's a weird crazy one its crispy
crunchy peanut butter
but it's not really peanut butter it's
like candied peanut butter which I mean
I I've always liked it well interesting
texture too but I like the caramelized
peanut butter not my thing I frankly
loved that we I can see why it's good
but like I'm not into peanut butter in
candy I think it's because I didn't grow
up on that I think I think it's a bee
I'm with you on that beef it definitely
tastes like a good candy so I think I'm
okay would be just not my personal taste
I'd give it a C I'm going deep
what explain yourself
that's way too flaky just made a mess
everywhere it is I think it's a C in
that case because he really brought it
down with that D I guess it makes sense
nexted thoughts and Hot Tamales into T
Rosen yeah it is too flaky I mean I well
giving me and said the I said B
you can't do that both you know I didn't
pour almond joy so the only candy we
didn't like
yeah but almond joy does Baby Ruth is a
controversial one this is my mom's
favorite candy bar what should tell you
something it's literally it's like a
Snickers but worse that's what I've
always felt because it's just peanuts
you know I'll be like good I guess it's
like a Snickers without caramel toffee
it's got lots of peanuts for the peanut
lovers
I don't like it that much okay I'm not
into it no I'm not it's a see but yeah
see see I would say see too but again
I'm looking at that it's definitely
don't definitely better than a tootsie
roll
stop with the tootsie roll it's kind of
like a poor man's Snickers yeah that's
what I've always thought I'd give it a
deep in I I guess deep are you guys
trying to do at the same time yeah okay
so hold on no because I gave it a CE I'm
okay wait that D and everybody came in
and then I think it might be a D yeah
hmm I know I would never ever buy a Baby
Ruth like if I was in a store yeah I
would never buy a Baby Ruth ever Twix
this really [ __ ] go is here with a
and go s already I mean everybody loves
Twix you can crunch him off you can
share them with your friend you got the
perfect balance of caramel chocolate
cookie
I love the tube it's a great device for
eating snacks in a tube the proportions
are everything it's like the whopper
tried to do in a ball and failed
miserably
the Twix is everywhere at once there's
the Alpha Omega it's delicious
Wow s tier Twix is us
it's a personal a-plus so I could go s I
may as well hmm hmm as there's another
chocolate bar but you can probably guess
which but you so we have three oh yes
yeah I mean Twix really how how is them
and I'm not up there I don't understand
you guys well it's just at the end of
the date it's just chocolate its M&M
like the classiest okay fine but the
times have changed it's like saying you
know show me another like chocolate in
this kind of format that could compare
what M&M nobody's gonna try to do M&M
they've tried in Israel yeah come on
everything sucks in Israel I mean at the
end of the day it's like you know yeah
the first car was cool but now we got
Ferraris but okay you know so now with
the KitKat and the Reese's Peanut Butter
Cup is all that remains and frankly I
don't know where these ones are gonna
land the kick head is similarly
positioned in my mind as the Twix it's
got the cookie it's got the layers you
can break it you can share it it's
always bomb I love that you can break it
it's just well and these are the many
ones but the real ones you can break off
yeah you got the wafer cookie the
chocolate is really good it's like I
should eat chocolate in the best way mmm
I love it s as hard s s + SS s yeah
that's I think the Twitter go SS so I'm
gonna give it a f - Rick to even it out
I'm kidding I'm kidding I wouldn't do
that to you I do think that hooks is
better so I would give it a nail cake is
bad but everyone just said s right yeah
everybody else is
I like twigs but in a KitKat low okay so
there are less but their ball s
finally and a big part of it is just for
the design that you can break it it's
just I mean it's engineered to
perfection genius
now finally I mean Reese's Peanut Butter
Club classic as it gets
I'm a huge fan I love let me show you
the cup okay
there's so much chocolate the peanut
butter ratio is and fit as fantastic
dynamite it's genius in fact they have
these dark chocolate ones that are off
the chain but you a cross-section
there's so much chocolate
so I just like it's tough for me cuz mmm
your nut butter is not a thing in Israel
what is the most popular snack in the
whole country and yeah it's not been
invited oh wait it's not the same it's
peanut flavor yes what's the difference
I don't know it's not fair okay
there's literally a snack called bomba
in Israel that everybody's obsessed with
all people eat I don't know if I've just
eaten too much candy you know my
enthusiasm here yeah it's it wait what
is Bombo what does it taste like it's
just it's literally tastes like peanuts
we had it here in the office and get our
Trader Joe's oh oh oh you brought anyway
that was good what I'm saying she's like
I don't like peanut butter it's like
dude it's all you guys eat it's
different
I don't know butter has like a really
heavy tone to it the cup I given it but
I could be just because I've eaten too
much sweets and I might give it a s on a
different day to be honest it's an S for
me but and what I recognized yes for me
it's an S but I recognized chocolate
peanut butter combo isn't for everybody
so mm-hmm
Rob ibly gonna get brought down a little
bit but for me it's an S that's up there
with the greats
I don't like peanut butter yeah so you
go I know I give it a D
oh holy [ __ ] I think I that misses I
can't recognize that
a really good candy okay but not mine so
what you're ready
so between B and a and a and you don't
even like it be honest yeah because it's
so really it's really not for me but I
can tell that's a well made it's well
male that's real
I understand how classic I know that
it's a classic and I didn't ever grow up
here but what do you say - Zack gave it
a D on American that's not good cuz I'm
going D as well your neck starting to
hurt oh yeah Adam you know boosters give
them power encourage him Zack gave that
he look at that what was your rating
anything I gave it a name
okay so we have we have addy addy [ __ ]
it might be an SC yeah oh here we go is
this I think where I'm pretty happy with
this yeah we didn't happen because it's
candy almond joy needs to be after it
might as well be I'm sorry it's just I
would spill it at all o'clock is it I
mean this is the most popular candy in
the world so an act for for them to have
been around for all this time being that
bad wait oh I'm enjoying the most
popular candy in the world
well it's no I'm saying definitely not I
mean it's got like the two worst things
almonds and coconut and meres marsupial
it's a neat I don't think it's an enough
I'm sorry Zack okay and no amount of
gazing is gonna change my mind
I like it I think it's a good list I
think everybody should observe know that
guidelines but the Sun the candy corn is
the candy that is an F what do you think
if you think it should be enough it's
not even in consideration I think it
should be there but as the only I think
you guys are obviously freaking wrong we
don't like by the way this is the thing
about candy carton whenever you see it
it's always this much yeah like of all
the candies yeah this milk bags or a
bucket of candy schmudge it must be so
cheap to make this the day after
Halloween like go to any grocery store
and you'll see the biggest back a bag of
candy core for like $1 this [ __ ]
literally cost nothing to make it's so
Halloween though that's why they
probably keep those same packs for the
next year good hater ass well there you
have it
alright did pretty good overall you're
pretty good with that list oh my god ate
too much [ __ ] yeah haven't eaten much
from here no well what else we oh I have
some other videos I want to show you
though before we take off we swatched
off to fail on the hoop now ela this
one's for you as you guys know I love
Instagram food there's all kinds of
interesting fascinating amazing
inspiring things this one inspired me I
think I found a recipe to make for ela
for dinner tonight
this is a burrito where instead of
tortilla it's fried cheese check it off
mute so the guy literally you know fries
cheese puts the astata lips it into a
god damn burrito that's pretty amazing
isn't it that's Quito
[Laughter]
there should be no diet in the world
where you're allowed to eat that you
know anything that is a hundred percent
keto you know is bad if you can eat that
well I mean it's kind of I mean do you
wake up the next day after you die in
your sleep by the way it's pretty cool
though it's pretty inventive don't you
say it is but I would not touch that I
would I would definitely I mean I would
take a bite it's kind of like an omelet
just without the egg it's just just the
cheese through that though anyone who
could actually heat that whole thing
really really is looks bomb yeah yeah I
knew you would like it I love that
that's keto though it is I know it is
and that's why I think he'll such
bullsháá well anyway it's fascinating no
matter how you cut it you got any
feeding window updates if anyone who's
going great I mean I'm really sticking
to it it really works for me
personally I like to be able to get
breakfast and dinner and I'm done I mean
it really works for me the biggest
problem I have I think is after our
snacking and vegging and extra meals so
when I cut myself off around 6:00 then I
think that that that really keeps my
weight in control well see I'm not been
weighing myself I feel like weighing
myself discourages me some people like
it so we will don't like when I lost
like all that weight before you came to
Santa Cruz I never weighed myself I had
no idea what I weighed at any time it
was just all I'm with you I don't like
weighing myself trying to gain or lose I
feel like you can see you can see what's
happening in the number I don't think
the goal should be long-term it
shouldn't be short-term because
sometimes you put on weight after a day
and you don't know why and it discourage
you or sometimes you lose a bunch of
weight and then the next it's just it's
a long-term process I just for me having
that focus on that day to day short-term
is uh unhelpful I just want to keep
doing this for as long as I can and you
know see where we are in a couple months
but it is work
you definitely and I'll tell you after I
ate all this candy I certainly don't
feel like eating anything else for the
rest of the day I feel like ass
feel awful yeah it's disgusting isn't it
crazy in which I'm kind of worried as
like as a parent how do you let your kid
do this that's what always that's the
eternal struggle of Halloween because
kids fill up an entire pillow sack of
candy and then the parent needs to do
somehow not make their kid hate them
forever and also I think what most
parents do and probably what we'll do is
like when they're sleeping you go throw
out a little bit every day what because
that way they think that's so shady
what do you how else are you gonna okay
what do you what how do you do it
without making your kid hate you I don't
know yet that I think that's a good idea
every night Ruggiero did you finish all
your candy okay yes and do you think
your parents probably they did now I
mean I never suspected that at the time
or I'm never thought about until now but
I'm telling you a lot there was like a
million calories of candy in my in my
soul possession you know what the trick
is you gotta have multiple kids so that
when they do notice the candy
disappearing they blame each other hit
them against each other but I feel like
there's gotta be you need to control
this because I'm telling you when you
see Theodore come home I'm already
worried its way crazier than this you
know but the sad thing about Halloween
because you've never experienced physik
when you eat all your favorite [ __ ] and
then what you're left with at the bottom
is just the sad enough like for me it
was nerds it was right Jolly Ranchers it
was a peanut we didn't get circus
peanuts what the hell you guys well
those are after those dude circus
peanuts would have been a half for sure
I don't never I don't even know what
that is there's the gummy ones circus
yeah they're like orange peanut like
fluffy pseudo oh I know
awful I'm telling you that would have
gone oh that would have been easier yeah
maybe yeah oh yeah disgusting yeah
gross yeah they were disgusting so those
were at the bottom that's a sad sight
when you're like I don't even want to
eat this candy like yeah you know ask
what about licorice what do you guys
think of liquor love yeah hard love big
love big beautiful love fan personally
love black licorice love red licorice
I even like purple licorice I've never
been a fan and I'm kind of just don't
sometimes I'll kind of like it that's
weird
I mostly don't like it fascinating
mm-hmm sorry I mean the don't clean you
but we were all talking about licorice
but I have to seesee in here who did a
Halloween special on his Instagram page
and as you know czn always turns up
always so welcome to czn halloween
bonanza Ethan Bradberry stop you could
put on the music I think it's the
vengers music I don't know about oh it
is okay Nicole
I thought they had like YouTube loyalty
free [ __ ] it's like so Ethan Bradberry
spider-man Elsa so they shot it all
backwards
for I don't know what reason I guess so
that so that the spider-man can look
like he's jumping up there but that
wasn't that bad and then well I guess it
was also it could look like he's pulling
it out with secret powers but yeah Iron
Man doesn't have super person do you
know what I'm saying nice cinematography
what with his mask would have worked
either way no he gravitated the pizza
out of the oven oh oh I see what you
mean
you can't do that Iron Man doesn't have
that power he he'd figure out a way what
what well I get tony would figure a way
out and well regardless just four point
three million views so
the reveal that smile yeah yeah that
helmets sick I want that helmet um so Oh
we had like the Twitter ban I mean who
gives a [ __ ] just taste this we have the
anal fissures yeah did you do some
follow-up on the anal fissures I did
uh-huh what did you learn and I heard it
I've been getting a lot of heat what I
said yeah so okay so I guess I was
improperly advised the person was just
[ __ ] with me well you reveal who that
person was uh it's an ant Oh your aunt
got you good she's lucky she got her
[ __ ] inverted so but I did I did okay
I I do have a doctor friend close to my
family who you know is this proctologist
and said sometimes they put Botox I
write I find that very interesting did
they do do that Zach so well I I was
hoping that you were right because it's
so funny but so I do apologize I was
wrong there certainly was a lot of
backlash against Zach in the comments
people said Zach knows nothing about
anal fissures why would I they said
you're either poorly describing lateral
internals this is a good one
finked errata me sphincter oh no Meah
that's funny is that where they put the
Botox up your ass
whoever had the surgery was a very rare
case of someone who had chronic anal
fissures that required an anal
reconstruction that's hot or they had
some other non fishery lated pain in the
ass why do they have to have vision
which look the funniest word ever
combined with inside your [ __ ] like
it's just so funny an anal fissure Zach
for your educational purpose we were
recommended a very informative video
that I think you should watch called
what is an anal fissure okay so Zach
this is for your a little purpose how
explicit is this going to be no it's
just married
they're just talking yeah so this is a
YouTube channel called talking with
doctors and they brought like a
proctologist to talk about you know four
years ago to middle and the guy in the
left can't even really keep a straight
face even even he's a doctor what are
you gonna talk about today so I thought
another very important topic was anal
fissures I'm really so oftentimes I'll
see people in the office who present
saying that they have a hemorrhoid but I
think it's very important that people
know that not all pain in the butt are
actually related think she likes ass but
you to know like if your proctologist do
you like ass player you know I guess the
real differentiation with probably don't
work yeah I don't know you probably do
they probably find the prostate like a
mother also related to a really hard
bowel movement that passed and then all
subsequent bowel movements cancers going
to look really painful whereas it
actually comes out you feel a sharp
stabbing debility even potentially
spasms in your pelvis as well okay so
that would be the hallmark symptom of
slowly following along that make a note
yeah which differentiates from
hemorrhoids because hemorrhoids will
have painful hemorrhoids will have an
obvious lump where with a fissure you
won't see a lump you'll and sometimes
you won't even see the little tear
fissures a tear in the
in the largest College reaction
excruciating pain I think it might be
sure what do I do
so the first thing and most important
thing is actually get a clear diagnosis
of what is giving you the pain but start
you're all brand buds quarter-cup
everyday things love's going to be all
brand new i regulate your bowels
regulators that was relevant regulation
about regulators mown up it was about
them taking the Metamucil money what I
think it is one of Muslim graduates yeah
no I mean you don't want a big heart
don't miss this for you one of the
biggest office bomb it's not hard not
too hard like Goldilocks I think it you
gotta stretch it out you got to stay
limber the sphincter so so basically you
already watch this video you want a big
car or you want a big poop but something
yeah because you want to basically
massage the sphincter as it comes out
and you really want to avoid those anal
fissures yeah so bases so the fissure is
when you poop basically cuts you on the
way out right it's a big bowl Duras you
ever had a [ __ ] you ever I mean I've had
one of those before work
I don't get them often but man those
things are crazy they like softball it's
like giving birth and they just you can
feel your [ __ ] tearing up you're like
oh it's so painful you know what I mean
you guys get the lottery you you how
regular are you um I did when I was
younger I gotta say being vegetarian you
poop pretty healthy it's good for that
that's good I had this when I was
younger to I don't really have it no I
think Zac probably is gnarly poops
well I've
taquitos jet absolutely I have a slight
case of IBS so that's good right no but
I mean IBS mixture but he gives you like
diarrhea no yeah it could hit you at the
worst times like I had to pull over on
the side of the road like yeah but it's
not you don't get the fissures you don't
get desiring fortunately no well that's
good yeah the diarrhea is bad obviously
yeah
Ian EMI have some monster sheds that's
not too bad not too much blood I got a
piece so I've been out of I haven't had
a bloody [ __ ] in a while though so
I'm glad we're all good but I gotta say
I can't speak highly about Metamucil
enough yeah I mean Metamucil is amazing
anyone who's tried is like the shiver
rules well it helps me like both ways if
I'm constipated or if like today either
way it's just the center you know what
evens yeah yeah it's like what the
Buddha talked about the center path the
center row a middle way the middle way
yeah he was talking about me not too
soft not too hard not too soft the
middle I was good that's that's in the
enlightened path right there so let me
ask when you guys are on the toilet do
you like to enjoy it or are you more of
like a quick and get I'm not quick and
get out okay I do it so fast I love it I
take my time I don't like when it takes
too long what I hate but since I started
using baby wipes the wiping doesn't
usually take too long and I'm happy to
announce today on the show that we
bought some tote oh yeah electric crazy
our new place does not allow for
flushing baby wipes because it had a
certain septic system and as well that's
that's everything I'm not worried about
the city I'm just worried about what
were those things called oh yeah they
were called uh-oh the sewage monsters
they were called something Oh fat burn
yeah
so anyway I'm off baby whyne so I gotta
get this Toto do vase so the seat comes
up and it shoots hot warm water at your
butthole you finally got on the bidet
yeah there all this time alright well I
had to get to the totem but yeah it's
ever been there right yesterday I mean
it's DB day yeah you can control the
angle of the water you it's got warm
water you can control the pressure how
do you the pressure of the water and I'm
still not quite sure how I'm gonna get
out of there without wiping though
because well I've had this we've had
this we'll see everyone says that it's
possible I guess well I mean you know
what I could do is have a baby wipe that
I clean up with it and throw it out yeah
cuz there's not gonna be a ton of [ __ ]
on it it's just to make sure cuz I like
to make sure yeah you gotta make you
know what I did yesterday that I haven't
done since I was like 5
this is embarrassing to admit but I was
having like really itchy [ __ ] which
and I put vaseline on my butthole yeah I
took the baby Vaseline for healing
why are you - I don't know I may have a
fissure
I I get I get what you're talking about
did you did say that you get itchy when
you have a fish after I think she said
the healing process oh yeah I I don't
think it's bad it's just I think but you
know what it is is that I haven't used
baby wipes in a long time and I'm using
a lot of toilet paper and I think like I
think that's irritating my my butthole
and it's gettin itchy site I just [ __ ]
scooped some Vaseline up there and it
actually was really nice it helped a lot
it's almost instantly isn't it yeah no
it was amazing I thought my it was gonna
feel all gooey and nasty but it didn't
at all I I was talking about I should do
this every day
I should keep my [ __ ] nice and like
lit moist yeah so you can insert you can
surf
[Laughter]
okay I don't know if we all needed to
know that yeah
well honestly what didn't you need to
know I mean really at the end of the day
and all it knowledge is not much
knowledge is a it's very objective to
continue on the Fisher I got an email
from a fan Zack hi I'm from Australia so
the figure surgery may be different here
because the other way get it but I like
to tell you my experience to assist your
recent debate I obtained the Fisher when
I was 17 years old and I didn't know
what it was at the time so I just
ignored it for years big mistake
that's what I'm doing right now I'm just
putting Vaseline on I thought pain and
bleeding was normal I didn't have a
close relationship with my parents so I
never opened up to them about the issue
this Liat led to long term constipation
problems even now eleven years later due
to the pain preventing me from using the
bathroom for weeks at a time
Wow oh god poor guy oh it's a girl Kayla
poor Kayla end up seeing a doctor when I
was 19 and he prescribed me cream that I
had to insert into my butt hole three
times a day that's what I was doing
it's almost embarrassing even when
you're by yourself it's like it's just
me some Vaseline a finger and my [ __ ]
knowledge and your finger really goes in
there too cuz it's all the dope with the
Vaseline okay so it's like [ __ ] well it
was crazy you want to know more no this
was an unpleasant experience that never
held my issue really I liked it I ended
up being referred to a specialist after
a year of using this cream and this
specialist insisted that I had to keep
using the cream
I was also put on laxatives by the time
I was 22 the specialist finally agreed
to perform the surgery he said that it
was very painful and the success rate
was not good which is why they persisted
with the cream for so long
turns out the procedure
fix the fissure was to cut another piece
of my anus muscle which would allow for
more blood to flow to the to reach the
torn piece and help it heal I was put to
sleep for the actual procedure so didn't
field thing was horribly painful
recovery though but it was worth it to
no longer have the pain of taking a
giant dump I couldn't sit for days and I
had to have a lukewarm bath of salt
water twice a day for four weeks to
prevent an infection in my anus and lots
of laxatives - I'm now 28 years old and
I have a perfectly happy healthy butt
hole so it has a very happy ending
fantastic and as she says I hope this
helps report thank you for reading Kayla
so Zack she did have the fissure surgery
okay and I will have to read it again
but I didn't read anything about
flipping the anus well it was an
exaggeration what I was told I see so I
do apologize I wish that was a real
tight dude like imagine getting a fresh
tight young anus I'm sure they can do it
imagine cuz mine is all worn out I've
been putting blah Vaseline all over it
you flipped that baby around ooh fresh
anus it's like flipping the pill oh yeah
here's some feedback for you Eva hey
that's it that was the feedback
Kevin writes dear Ella I'm a die-hard h3
podcast fan I have listened to every
episode at this point I am an exclusive
iTunes audio listener that's interesting
and I'm being 100% serious when I tell
you that eating segments are the best
part of the podcast I'm usually on your
side either but I have to go with Ethan
on this one well I do not enjoy the
sounds of you've been crunching away on
lettuce it doesn't bother me and in fact
I feel that eating segments are so
informative and interesting it's as if
I'm watching a must
much less dignified report of the week
that's for sure nobody's more dignified
than him
now I know not to get talked about
salads what a great thing to know now I
can avoid that cancer being more
informed by the podcast I've shown the
segment's to my friends and they all
agree you'll the eating segments are the
best I truly believe that the eating
segments enhance the show profoundly
thank you for taking your time to read
this email and please please do more
food reviews in the future I suggest you
try fast food soups huh do they serve
soup at fast food I've never ever heard
that my life Kevin I don't know if I
believe in you think he's being ironic
oh well you probably read some comic
Stan what do people think about the
eating the salad section dance
headphones are messed up so of course
well basically we've got the millionaire
I puts it together a segment of people
getting the first question wrong a
millionaire which I thought was great
it's always fantastic but that that's
evergreen is it not sure so we also have
the Twitter let's talk about Twitter
more wrapped up want to give a big shout
out to Jack Dorsey I believe is his last
name who announced epically that Twitter
is banning all political ads how cool is
that very interesting he said a
political message earns reach when
people decide to follow an account for
retweet paying for each removes that
decision forcing highly optimized and
targeted political messages on people
I'm not reading all this I'm over it
but basically what he's saying which I
like that he's saying this isn't about
free speech because I hate that all
these companies like Facebook always
their their big excuses like oh it's
free speech we don't want a home free
speech funny idiot it's not free
expression or whatever well and first of
all it's a private company and second of
all well here's the here's the
difference is if you take out an ad on
broadcast like let's say CNN and you
there has to be some
truth and advertising for example I have
this clip of of AOC asking the Zack for
example here I mean I thought I thought
this was was a very telling moment in
primary is saying that they voted for
the green new deal would I be able to
run advertisements on Facebook
targeting Republicans in primaries
saying that they voted for the green new
deal I mean if you're not fact-checking
political advertisements I'm trying to
understand the bounds here I think so
you don't know if I'll be able to do
that I don't think you could do that on
broadcast to just outright like smear
somebody she says could I target a
Republican and say he voted for the
green new deal which obviously is to
them like you know it's targeting a
liberal and saying they voted to make
abortion illegal or something similar to
that I would imagine and it if it's just
patently false that I mean does the
platform have a responsibility to to
control that messaging because right now
I think we are in the middle of a
information crisis and that's what Jack
talks about he says here I don't know if
you're right though I think they you
could run it on television I don't think
so I think that is part of the
conversation no the part of the
conversation is that on on social media
there's no auditing there's no
verification and people are just taking
it all at face value if you go to a
major broadcasting network and try to
run an ad like that they're gonna say no
cuz it's an outright lie and I think
there are truth in advertising laws it
gets really tricky with political ads
there are yeah but the FCC has a very
light touch with that kind of stuff
because they don't want to appear
partisan but what you just said is
correct it the the stations generally
yeah they'll they'll refuse to Erin had
if it's just like you can't just be like
[ __ ] you know you can't just run an
ad and be like yeah and Zuckerberg Joe
dances Donald Trump attended a Nazi
rally
I mean it's like you you know what I
mean right and so Facebook doesn't have
that they don't care and Jack very
wisely said internet political ads
present an entirely new challenge to
civic discourse machine learning based
optimization of messages and micro
targeting unchecked misleading
information and deep fix all
increasingly velocity sophistication and
overwhelming scale
this isn't about free speech is about
paying for reach and paying to increase
the reach of political speech has
significant ramification that's today's
democratic infrastructure may not be
ready to handle it's worth stepping back
in order to address I mean how how cool
is that that's so nice I think that he's
he's putting a you know our democracy
ahead of Twitter's earnings and you know
when you see little [ __ ] boy suck here
who's like he's doubling down I mean
they here let's see a little more after
an hour of Jack announcing that they'll
no longer run political ads Facebook
doubles down says Google YouTube and
most Internet platforms run these same
ads most cable networks run these same
ads and of course national broadcasters
are required by law to run them by FCC
regulations I think there are good
reasons for this in a democracy I don't
think it's right for private companies
to censor political called politicians
or the news and although I've considered
whether we should not carry these ads in
the past and I'll continue to do so
unbalanced so far I've thought we should
well here and then to follow that up
again it's like she says if you're out
like I'm lying
I mean you know it's it's a it's a clear
and present danger I think in terms of
we have it we have a issue of
information there's too much information
we'd a lot of you don't know what's real
what's false it's super hard to know
what's real what's false
and when people are exploiting that as
Jack said you have algorithms in
real-time crunching data manipulating
people
- that's why it's just not real I can't
stand when Mark is trying to defend it
with free speech because it has nothing
to do with that yeah it's it's not
really speech it's really just like
large-scale emulation I think you Jack
Dorsey explain it like when you follow
someone and then you see their feed
that's free speech but when someone is
paying for rich you're gonna see
something that is not something you
would have it's not natural they're
paying for rich so it's not there's
nothing like here he's a he's about said
a free speech and paid speech are not
the same thing our current policies on
fact-checking people in political office
or those running for office are a threat
to what Facebook oh yeah employees of
Facebook are now rebelling 250 employees
of Facebook wrote a letter to the zuc
asked him to change his policy they're
concerned that Facebook is a place for
free expression and they worried that
the policies will undo the work that has
been done since 2016 election to fight
misinformation free speech they said and
paid speech are not the same thing our
current policies on fact-checking and
political office and those running for
office are a threat to what Facebook
stands for after the recent controversy
over Facebook's political ad policy
where Zuck essentially has said that
politicians can literally lie and
advertisements on the platform the
company is getting pushed back
internally was signed by 250 employees
who are now unemployed sucks put them in
the meat grinder it's like a meat meat
on day
contrary like their argument against the
doors is decision set is saying that
removing a major source of low cost
political advertising from Twitter harms
those who don't yet have a large
audience but are looking for an
inexpensive way to reach votes and
identify new supporters so I don't find
people think that that's the reason why
it should be allowed
dude that is such a minor consequence of
litter I feel like nobody actually
thinks that yeah it's so great he said
no political ads it's the only way you
can do this nobody no plea even said no
single policy ads either like if it's a
single issue of like gay marriage was a
big one or whatever gun rights marijuana
stuff like that no political ads the
only political as they're allowing are
to get people to register to vote that's
the only ones they allow I think it's
fantastic
I think that it's become too
sophisticated to manipulative that these
these platforms are posing too great of
a threat to the information exchange of
knowing what's really going on and I
think these kinds of debates and
conversations need to be happening not
on social media
and I applaud that move and I think Mark
Zuckerberg is a sociopath I think he may
be a psychopath he certainly is placing
the value of Facebook above the welfare
of the entire world at large I think
that the dude is super rich and he's got
like a $30 haircut I don't know why the
dude likes to smoke meats and he's gonna
end up smoking civilization if he
doesn't get his [ __ ] together good smoky
flavor such a weirdo so I do have to you
have to say I went and looked up the
rules and it's true that what he says TV
networks there they aren't allowed to
reject ads because they find it
objective all or miss Lee
like the rules against false advertising
and the kind of stuff which is probably
what you're thinking of do not apply to
political ads so basically yes you could
that's what I rely on TV as well yeah
the same way that you can on Facebook I
feel like there's got to be more to that
I mean we're not experts on this field
but I don't think that it's perfect on
TV no way there's a guy there's got to
be more regulation than not fit on
Facebook you can literally you can say
me there's crazy conspiracies like this
circulated on Facebook that like Hillary
Clinton is a child molester and like a
lot of people believe that [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying like you can
run that on Fox News
well stuff like that I mean you're right
they would probably deem that
inappropriate and you got to understand
too that there's a distinction between
what a candidate can put out and then
what like these PACs which are sort of
these kind of gray area independent it's
all packed school right and so the laws
don't apply to packs like the laws
saying like you can't censor a
politician that I don't there's some God
did there's better government prevents
from censoring political ads censoring
but that doesn't mean I can run ads
saying that Elizabeth Warren a you know
drinks the blood of children yeah good
because it gets hard to decide what what
is false you know what makes it false
what makes it false yeah that she
blinked that she drinks the blood of
children okay no I understand but I just
something that you don't do the level of
[ __ ] on something to a Republican would
look right to a Democrat would look like
a life so hard that's what you see on
Facebook is a coordinated intelligent
algorithmic there's what they're doing
is serving it on such a granulated level
where they go
it's more complicated and it's a
difference but nothing but we're talking
about the point that you said that on TV
you won't see fake eyes you do I think
okay it's different they don't have the
smart algorithm like social media does I
think the difference is again I I mean
can't be back that seems overly
simplistic I have a hard time believing
that that I could run an ad saying
elizabeth warren trench baby but if you
if you are the candidate like if you are
running for governor or whatever and you
run and you want to pay for an ad that
says that your opponent in the race you
know has sex with animals or something
you could do that and but not a PAC is
what you're saying a PAC couldn't do it
on your behalf
right so I think on Facebook you have
organizations not the candidate who are
REME most ads are coming from PACs like
you said yeah so on Facebook you can
have you go on in Kansas in this or this
it's the small subset of males who
follow this page in the city get really
activated when they see that Elizabeth
Warren drinks baby blood what's going on
in Facebook okay but on the on
television it's not like that it's not
just black or white it's like I'm just
reading now like you know how so when
they're in commercials they can use like
language that may suggest something but
doesn't say necessarily like like the
top brand of laundry it doesn't say
we're number one but it it it's a
language that will imply that they're
number one so and they do the same okay
there's misleading ads but the level of
the of [ __ ] you see that's coming from
Facebook is another level and but and
like what Dan said okay if you put your
candidates face on the television you
say Elizabeth Warren
[ __ ] animals and say this message and I
my name is George Bush and I approve
this message right that's different than
some anonymous PAC
there's just running all this
straight-up slanderous [ __ ]
on Facebook that's happening and on they
have and they're so good at doing it
that they're based they are literally
affecting what people see as real yeah I
mean look at Hillary I agreed that it
needs a different treatment yeah and I
think and I think Zuckerberg is
purposely taking advantage of the fact
that these things are very complicated
yeah most people don't have a grasp on
it I mean it he's definitely you haven't
even gone into there's distinction
between broadcasts networks you know
like NBC ABC you know the lower stations
versus cable like there's distinctions
between those things too so there's like
a lot of layers - yeah it's definitely
playing dumb but you know and and and
that only goes to show how much money he
makes from that all right right this was
just a couple million bucks or even 10
20 million bucks he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
he would take the good PR and he would
cancel the whole thing
but how much money is actually all this
dark money is flowing into Facebook
because they go well I can't run this
[ __ ] on Fox News but if I go on Facebook
I can basically it's like the Cambridge
analytical [ __ ] they're like I can reach
every I can literally change the
election on Facebook with 50 million
bucks they're all they're making so much
money off this [ __ ] making so much money
and all those people that say oh it's
silly you know Facebook ads aren't
swinging an election or whatever they
wouldn't be spending this kind of money
on it right it didn't have an impact and
and I thought and Zuck wouldn't be
taking this bad PR if it was that little
money yeah exactly
he's part dude they're probably making
money like you can even guess they're
probably making hundreds hundred million
dollars yeah for sure I mean it's just
crazy
he's definitely I don't know it's acts
like he's scary it's weird cause it's
like oh he's I was trying to try to like
defend his actions with free speech and
whatever but is actually doing like real
dark well look back there's these these
famous leak - dams with luck when first
made Facebook at Harvard you said
something like these idiots just give me
whatever they want I have all their
social security numbers and driver's
license number just let me know if you
want him and the
person says why did they give it to you
says I don't know they're [ __ ] idiots
like verbatim that's what he said about
people on the beach I mean he's a meat
chef but like sweet baby I do think he
probably has some kind of clinical I
mean I do think he probably has some
kind of sociopathy he must yeah he does
come off it's a little off doesn't he
well yeah I would think that like if my
company had so much responsibility that
you could actually like affect the
elections I would want to take more
action well Jack did yeah that's awesome
yeah and I hope that that amounts
pressure against Facebook to do the same
thing I clearly did but I will say about
they they put a statement that they're
not gonna do anything well we'll see I
mean it yeah they did but I'll tell you
Facebook's tools are so robust man we've
done some mild testing with like
marketing on with Teddy fresh and for
whatever reason the Facebook returns are
always like insanely better than the
Google AdWords stuff but Facebook is
always just such is it actually better
or is it just telling you well just
going off of like what it tells you how
many impressions are our I think it's
actually better okay and you know they
got sued and lost about the whole thing
with faking views yeah yeah on the video
when you were buying impressions and
yeah no this this is based I mean we
have all the cookies and it's like
straight up conversion and everything
right yeah yeah but man I mean I just
don't get it I don't know what's going
on on Facebook well because they've
spent over a decade now building up an
extremely detailed profile on what like
over half of the country I mean almost
everybody that's a Facebook at this
point right I used yeah anymore I mean I
don't use mine at all no yes but it's a
long time though so I mean they still
got that info on me yeah I hope they saw
us I swear I hope the Facebook died so
bad
I'll make meats now smoking these meats
here such a word over the smoked meats
yes it's just his attempt to look human
I wonder what he does on his free time
he's probably does I could totally see
him doing that smoky flavor though so I
think that's it we've done it all we've
seen it all we've talked about anal
fissures what you want to play golf sure
I'd love to I feel like [ __ ] there's a
lot of candy oh we have The Witcher
trailer you want to watch that let's not
get claimed over a dump yeah yeah
whatever honestly I hope you guys all
had a great Halloween I'm very happy
with how my costume turned out thank you
to the boys back hey making that happen
either looked fantastic Dan what the
slamming looked fantastic
Ian looks fantastic he's still balancing
it on his head well done Ian and only by
the grace of Zach's beautiful gaze was
he able to make it through it and
basically this is this is why we're here
I mean miles ACK no gate no it's adults
mile brats it don't think about all the
horsey sauce don't listen to her so much
well guys i had a lot of fun here on
this halloween bonanza I had a lot of
fun lots of laughs gaffes goofs were had
I don't like candy anymore I'm over it
and that's it so taste Friday that's
pretty cool hope you all have a blessed
weekend a fantastic let's all go and do
nothing how does that sound
I'm in baby you know me I'm always in
for that
these doggies are ready to get at her
they were good boys though I love you
guys so much I mean a burro Hashem got
blessed and everything else that rabbi
would say during a sermon what something
a rabbi would say he would say listen
you would you go home you must remember
actually have no idea what they would
say they would say you must remember to
always when you have sex you must put a
hole in the sheet for your dick to pass
through because God God knows that you
mustn't lust over your wife even when
you're having sex so that's why we put
the hole in the sheet that's what they
do right the Orthodox honestly they put
a hole in the sheet and they have sex
through the hole that sounds kind of hot
that's a good thing like some weird porn
yeah like just a dick to Oishi though
but then how do they have sex do this
does he lay over her and the sheet no
idea because I imagine it's like doggy
style but then that means you would have
to pin the sheet up and then the girl
would have to do some kind of balancing
act seems complicated well I'll look
that up later tonight there's probably
some some kind of there's some sub
subcategory there and well that's it
guys and I and I and I hope all right
guys thank you have a blessed blessed
beautiful weekend tell the people in
your life you love them tell the people
in your life they all that you hate that
you don't hate them cuz you don't hate
that's not what God would tell you to do
I'm a rabbi right now so and say
blessings for the beautiful food do you
eat on your dinner table because there
we don't have the bless I mean I mean
Moses walk down I'm raiding is that the
sex through the [ __ ] is a mate nobody
ever [ __ ] to a sheet I had a feeling
though I'm utterly well logistically it
doesn't make any sense right
well do some research for Bob say
blessings for the food Moses walked
through the desert he didn't have food
god damn it so be a goddamn prayer and
speed hack be goddamn thankful that
you're here on this earth because a lot
most things never even get to exist at
all
but you do exist and so you know what
damn it get out there and exist the [ __ ]
out of it that's what God said when he
created the earth the [ __ ] out of it now
this play it created the earth so and
the Spirit of God and I and I and I so
bad
alright let's wrap it up thank you guys
thank you for watching nobody made it
this far if you did make it this far say
and I poop
God said say this God said on the
seventh day and I hope and he knew his
creation was complete yeah let's go hang
out with shredder love you guys
thank you for watching stay blessed keep
the dick swinging and [ __ ] to a sheet
brush brush your teeth definitely
[Music]